es un nombre poco común y muy rara vez
se escucha hablar de él no que un
agente nervioso y letal detectado en el
organismo del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni según expertos hace parte de una
familia de sustancias químicas que en la
década de los 60 eran utilizadas como
insecticida este este medicamento pues
actúa principalmente en el sistema
nervioso autónomo y también puede
afectar a los músculos la intoxicación
principalmente se caracteriza por
salivación broncoespasmo e hipotensión
caída la tensión arterial y también
puede terminar en paro cardiaco y a
nivel muscular puede haber parálisis
muscular lo que lleva un paro
respiratorio que es lo que finalmente
causa la muerte es la misma sustancia
que en 2018 puso en coma al ex espía
ruso serguéi skripal y a su hija giulia
en un reino unido- y aunque ambos se
recuperaron cuatro meses después una
mujer murió tras haber estado expuesta
al novillo
vitalidad va a depender de la dosis
estos pueden actuar tan rápido como 510
segundos y matar a una persona en 15
minutos tal vez pero todo depende de la
cantidad que llegue al cuerpo y de la
forma como ingresé puede ser a través de
la piel puede ser a través de las vías
respiratorias este tipo de arma química
fue creada por la unión soviética en las
décadas de los 70 y 80 pero no son los
únicos capaces de desarrollarla en los
componentes y la síntesis de estos
productos no es tan compleja y podría
ser preparado en cualquier país en donde
se disponga de los elementos que
prácticamente en cualquiera de ellos de
acuerdo con expertos en armas químicas
el no que es poco detectable y
está diseñado para superar las
capacidades de defensa química de la
otan